it's telling me i must eat a cow's
kidney
what
cow's kidney i don't even know if i can
do that yeah see how everyone's laughing
behind the back that means bro you're
gonna suffer
[Music]
lumpy it my brothers don't eat crumpets
bow it's your favorite lv general lump
it slump it my brothers don't eat
crumpets and welcome back to elvis full
fit roulette the objective of the show
is to spin the wheel wherever it lands
on you have to do a full fit yo guys so
today we got on the show my brother from
another mother one of the funniest guys
in the game right now ty logan
bam bam bam bam
[Applause]
because when i see you sometimes i don't
know why you you didn't call me the
other day as well bro come on man i'm
always calling you i tried to call you
you didn't call me back anyway let me
get on with the show man it's your boy
tyler and don't ruin it we're doing it
i'm gonna be real with you my boy alvey
called me down he said cars we've got
saturn gear none i said what's going on
he said we're gonna be eating stuff
playing certain games we see owls can't
trust them man there and my second guest
today job man
[Applause]
um i don't really know why i'm here but
all i know is good experience i'm gonna
get lit today man trust me let me just
tell you what the rules before we even
start yeah
yeah because it's in front of me you're
number one one and he's number three
yeah and there's a number four that's
the general knowledge question okay yeah
so when you go into that question there
i'll pick a question out of this box
here am i right the blue ones yeah yeah
and if you get it wrong bro if you get
it wrong
i'll go into this one now this is the
skull of death death i'm scared that's
why my belly's hurting i feel sick
already yeah you see this one here look
at him look at him very good yeah
you see when you go into this one i feel
sorry for everyone on the table
obviously i might get it anyone could
get it you understand
that bro i don't want to get it i'm
sweating already i can feel the nerves
kicking in if it lands on say it went on
to your own number yeah yeah for
instance then let me myself i've got to
go into the normal full fit box and
that's the standard not ready
you're ready and steady like freddie
on one [ __ ] off tonight
i have no idea what to expect but listen
i'm down for whatever so let's just get
cracking bro i'm not ready but we've got
to be ready you ain't giving me no
choice isn't it brother what do you want
me to do it's mad
jordan black got man sitting there
sweating let's get on with it man let's
go
[Music]
lump it slump it my brothers don't eat
crumpets
rock paper scissors
just like that when i'll pinch my
fingers you know
my fingers
[Music]
yeah straight in that's cool
have a spoonful of cat food for fake man
last time i had freaking dog food nice
cat
science not right bro
sun's not
dog food not even a dog treat man said
what's up when we read that what's this
one chicken breast carla genuinely i
just want to say um i hope you enjoy it
my brother
oh my king god it stinks
it stinks it stinks it's gonna make me
sick he stinks open that open let's see
you're scared oh look at that coleslaw
how come the dog food look like coleslaw
fat food's fat
come on
i'll do it
man bro you said a spoonful you saw
where is beautiful
on it bro sticky no i can eat the tip of
it if that was me but i would have
backed it already long time long time
really do it long time just
gone you don't have to see it with your
tongue just
listening
let me open up the water for you man
because you're doing too much cheating
well i don't want to do this man bro do
you even think about it
crack it quick
damn done
yeah strong come out
yes
you see you don't feel it man that's
what i'm saying feel it
i hate you man
i liked it he liked it
[Applause]
you're going my brother straight here
this game's man i'm praying to god i
don't get that box over there no because
if that's what you're giving man the
normal fulfillment forgot about him you
see what i'm saying i didn't forget
about him
energy over there needs to stay over
there because i don't want it coming
near me let me do a little spinner all
right it's got a spindle in it that's
the thing yeah that's a good spin
bro this is your show
it's just bro
you're lucky my brother you go out
[Applause]
oh
the game's sabotage look you can't spin
like that bro
you can't spin like that what do you
mean it went round it went round on the
surface i felt like it went around then
it has to go around it's not being spin
bro you see what's my dog if you landed
on your team did you think you would be
saying spin it again
bunny then in it blood yeah you want me
to spin it i spun it
allow me
tell me that one another spin
did i not spin it round it went round
and round went round round me
let me get the forfeit man do the
forfeit magnet in there sir
the magnet i'm [ __ ] bold can't play
like this blood stop setting me bam put
on what the f
what is going on
go through
put a tampon up your nose look for the
rest of the episode oh my god i can't do
that brother brother
you hear my scare non cause tampon that
man's nose
man do your thing run i can't do that
it's against my human rights i'll do a
full fit of something else no no if you
don't do this there's god do you want to
damage no no no no
no
again
[Applause]
no that's not fair brother next i'll go
back in the box and go again i've been
sacked by him already your steps gone
then no no no your step's gone your sex
[Music]
oh
general knowledge let me shuffle that
around a bit wait is this game about
killing me off a son i would say so well
i've been hurt many times
yeah oh this is an easy one brother i
got one for you what was invented first
twitter
or instagram you're asking the wrong
brother thank god you got that i'm going
to go to twitter
just like that just like that
correct correct correct
come on come on man i told you that was
the light one easy bro whoa girl easy
bro yo
yeah
whoa
see how he's laughing see how he's happy
again now go
let's go let's go
who holds the record for the most
premier league goals
oh my you ain't been watching football
you know me i'm a boxing man i'm the
only one who keeping the thoughts on i'm
the only one who can help you see right
now
if you know football and you know
certain man on the picture then you
should know already it's only going to
be a certain person who's going to be
the top goal scorer season of the
premier league
premier league though not even overruled
you should know that oh
you see if it was this season it'll be a
bit easier
but i heard a lot about that skull ones
you know i'm just gonna go for it say
his name then english man yeah rashford
rashford rashford it's not bossy
john
let's go
get it to me man
give it to me man what's the answer
though
thank
you old school that's why i said what
are you doing what generation are you in
yeah yeah and you didn't even
jump man
i said yeah yeah jaggers
they got me
you see right now
i'm going to be honest with you
after this next forfeit
i think i might be gone
i'm not doing this one maggie see i
would have loved it to be i don't like
chile
[Applause]
[Music]
little piece of it look look what he's
eating
no no look i'm not hearing that [ __ ]
give me two minutes man
you're so mad right now brother
you see me i'm not doing those for
entertainment again bro i'm done
it doesn't matter who it lands on it's
just pete i don't want to look it i
don't know
i
[Applause]
what's the biggest animal in the world
[Music]
well everyone got a clue
bro
what's the biggest animal that you can
think of an elephant that's it you don't
think there's anything bigger than that
no because i'm talking about animal in
it i'm thinking about animals what else
is bigger than an elephant bro
man
you like
it has to be an elephant
it just has to be
i can't see how it would be any other
animal
what's bigger than a [ __ ] elephant
i'm not helping nothing i'm staying
the biggest animal in the world come on
bro
huh
animals in the sea you've got animals in
the jungle what is the largest animal in
the world
bam
the blueberry blue really
hold on
do you know what
i feel like this whole game has been
spun on my head i would say so now
everything what's in there it's just
been spun on my head i was mad read that
you got me
let's go
oh my god does he me see my life bro see
my life you see my life it's him he he
knows i'm always but see what it is
you've passed your bad luck on there bro
last time we're going to see this [ __ ]
yeah he passes bad luck bro he's telling
me i must eat a cow's kidney
what
cow's kidney i don't even know if i can
do that yeah see how everyone laughing
behind the back that means bro you're
going to suffer so high
so how is a kidney edible
yeah
crazy oh why are you giving me little
bits i don't want to eat i don't want to
don't chew it just swallow it you got
this bro yeah i'm actually with you on
this one i'm with you i need a big water
bottle now
it's too much it's stinking this is
butters oh my god brother put that away
man so i'm gonna pull the floor i'll
just leave it man bro i beg you just
back bro i think
yeah yeah yes look at that
snap
come on don't talk to me someone's not
don't talk to me you're stuck in my
phone
can i get water please
you know man
that's a different one
no this game's not stat lands on two
yeah i'm done i'm going out the door i'm
going out the door now
the game's not fair you saw what just
happened
bro
he told me that says
my opponent gets to wax nah that's not
well done i forget to wax my legs
[Applause]
it's waxing
yeah
so just make sure you got the extra
in the clap roll just do it properly and
not don't rip my skin off my leg
right now make sure you layer it i've
done it now
i'm here
oh
[Applause]
i see you
no that's three no no no no no no no
that was booty
you cheated and it backfired you gotta
do yeah have a table not a tea a
tablespoon of chili powder
big boy you're a tea go relax
chill out
yeah yeah yeah chill out it's fine i
hope this is long yeah you see how i had
to do scotch money
yeah for the chili dad you know you
gotta do tell the ladies and gentlemen
we're scared
how dare tell me listen i've been doing
this yeah yeah i haven't really got say
too much because i'm some joke man
oh [ __ ] you cut from my face in that
mountain
bro
because
i'm gonna
don't even go
is
that was a mad spin though that was a
mad mad spin what you just did but yeah
yeah yeah
i was thinking
we're doing there
hold the pig's air in your mouth
that looks mad
that's too far guys you're gonna witness
the first time ever
my brothers don't eat crumpets
are they in his mouth
are you mad this show is
even though i got i got done for like
now
anyway use vlog
camera look at the camera see you next
week guys
let me know
come come come here